you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme now the growing
demand for gas around the world
could put global climate targets at risk
as nato troops withdraw from afghanistan
we look at the risks the country is
facing from the climate crisis
and green fingers raising awareness of
green
issues at the hampton court palace
garden festival
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and we're going to start today
at our data dashboard and take a look at
this
number here now this shows an estimate
of human-induced global warming since
the industrial revolution
in 2015 more than 190 countries signed
the paris agreement
to limit this number to two degrees
preferably
1.5 degrees to do that will require a
huge reduction in the use of fossil
fuels
such as oil and gas but according to the
international energy agency
global demand for gas is set to increase
putting aims to reach net zero emissions
by 2050 at risk well they found that in
2020
global natural gas demand dropped by 1.9
because of an exceptionally mild winter
in the north and the impact
of the covid19 pandemic but demand is
expected to rise by
3.6 this year as lockdowns ease and
economies
recover now part of the increase in
demand is thought to be because of high
temperatures driving demand for air
conditioning
across the northern hemisphere now in
recent weeks parts of the united states
and canada
have experienced record temperatures
while moscow recorded its hottest
ever june day and national records were
also set
in finland belarus and estonia
well the iea is forecasting that unless
major policy changes to curb global gas
consumption are introduced
demand will just keep growing by 2024
they estimate
an overall seven percent rise from
pre-covered levels and that would mean
global targets to reach net zero
emissions by 2050
would be missed well joining me now is
dr aj gambier senior research fellow at
imperial college london's grantham
institute for climate change
and the environment welcome to you it's
easy perhaps to understand why demand
for gas may have dropped during the
pandemic but why is consumption
tipped to rise so much in the years
ahead well i think that
as you were saying there's been this
rebound from the covid
19 pandemic we're seeing a lot of fast
economic growth in the number of regions
and a lot of our energy infrastructure
and assets
are still designed to work off fossil
fuels
now gas is if you like the cleanest of
the fossil fuels of coal oil
and gas but it's still too dirty
if we're to operate in a global economy
which is
trending towards net zero carbon dioxide
emissions which is what we need
to be on track to meet the paris
agreement goal uh of world below two
degrees celsius
and pursuing efforts towards 1.5 degrees
so you know we're seeing this economic
rebound and we're seeing that
uh depending if you like on a lot of gas
energy
but what we really need to do is
transition away from all fossil fuels as
quickly as possible
well yes and where does the onus for
that shift
lie are there some countries that are
more reliant on gas than others
i mean yes you know there are lots of um
countries
across the world in europe and elsewhere
um
that use a lot of gas in their power
generation
uh you know we've seen shifts from coal
to gas
fired power in the united states that
alone has actually been
responsible for a large reduction in
carbon dioxide emissions in the united
states
that might seem like a really good thing
but there's only so far that can go in
terms of moving us towards this net
zero carbon economy so you know there
are lots of countries like that which
have traditionally relied on
dirty or if you like coal-fired power
and are now using gas-fired power
but the real long-term solution comes
from zero carbon power
from renewables like wind and solar and
so on
and every country in the world has the
possibility of using a large share of
renewables
and other low carbon sources so i think
really the responsibility if you like is
in all countries of the world now to
have a clear and
defined pathway to shifting away from
all fossil fuels as quickly as possible
dr aj gambier thanks very much indeed
thank you
in today's other climate news the uk
needs to cut its global environmental
footprint by
75 percent by the end of the decade to
help nature
recover the wwf says the uk's impact on
climate is disproportionately high
but could be reduced through measures
such as reducing food waste and ensuring
all marine resources
come from sustainable sources
these last couple of years we've seen
just extraordinary outbursts of
you know fires around the world you know
the horrible fights we're seeing in
british columbia at the moment
cyprus i saw yesterday but yeah siberia
amazon australia we're seeing these
extreme weather events they those will
become the norms sadly
and we know that we're losing species
around the world as well and
don't forget since 1900 if 500
types of vertebrates have gone extinct
so these are animals no one will ever
see again
and that those risks will increase as if
we don't take action now
jonathan bartley is stepping down from
his role as green
party co-leader his fellow co-leader
sean berry will continue as acting
leader until a leadership election takes
place
bartley is the longest serving leader
the party has had and called his five
years there an
immense privilege
new zealand has experienced its hottest
june in more than a century
figures from the national institute of
water and atmospheric research
show the average temperatures were two
degrees higher than normal
despite a polar blast that hit the
country just last week
the niwa says the weather was a result
of high
sea level air pressure and climate
change
and the campaign to rewild the south
downs national park has been launched
13 000 hectares that's the equivalent of
21 000 football pitches
is set to be restored to its original
condition in order to create more
habitats for plants and animals
it's part of a un-backed initiative to
increase protected areas for nature by
30 percent by 2030.
afghanistan is one of the most
vulnerable countries in the world
to climate change but one of the least
well-equipped to cope with the
impact it may have and as nato troops
withdraw
there are concerns for how the country
will be able to adapt as the climate
crisis
intensifies well in a moment i'll be
speaking to the international rescue
committee's country director in kabul
but first here's a snapshot of some of
afghanistan's climate challenges
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
well joining me now from kabul is vicky
aiken afghanistan country director at
the international rescue committee
so vikki akin afghanistan extremely
vulnerable to climate change so what do
you think it could mean for the country
well we currently have 12.2 million
people
nearly a third of the population in
emergency
or crisis food insecurity so for example
many of the crops are being destroyed in
the fighting
um there are explosive remnants
of war contaminating fields
and then many of the highways
are blocked by the conflict so if a
farmer is
harvesting fresh produce and has to wait
five days or so to get his food to the
market
then that food is going to be destroyed
and how could climate change
manifest itself there in afghanistan is
the biggest worry
droughts or floods or avalanches how
could it play out
so it plays out all of the above in
different areas of the country we see
severe flooding and in others we see
severe droughts and in some of the areas
like bad geese in the west you see both
the last severe drought was just a
couple of years ago in 2018
and with that drought we saw more than a
quarter of a million people
displaced from their homes we hope this
time
to try to prevent people from leaving
their homes by providing
aid to them where they live um
it was a study done after the last route
showed that it took the average that it
would take the average person
16 years to pay off the debt they
accumulated
during those few months and
you know since then the country has been
devastated by the impact of covet
and the level of people
living under the poverty line has
increased from 50 to over
70 percent vicky aiken thanks very much
indeed
thank you now jobs in green industries
might not
only be good for the environment but for
our pockets too
the think tank onward has found that
industries such as renewable energy
could pay workers 30 more than their
carbon intensive counterparts
but the uk workforce is under prepared
for the transition to net zero
with the report saying more than three
million employees will need to
retrain in specialist skills and
technical qualifications
adam karen batter made the move from
working in oil to renewable energy the
trigger for me to transition at that
point
was more about the decline in the uh
in oil prices back in 2014-15
so i really needed to pivot to a market
that was looking more
healthy and buoyant and by luck i was
given the chance to really start
recruiting into renewable energy
which is now my my uh mainstream
business
oh absolutely it's the one of the best
decisions
uh i've made in my career if not the
best and finally it's a blooming good
year for climate change awareness
at the hampton court palace garden
festival gardens that highlight
efforts to tackle plastic pollution and
the impact of fast fashion
all feature at the event horticultural
hero tom stewart smith's garden
includes a climate resilient meadow
showcasing
plants that grow in hot conditions and
are becoming increasingly common in the
uk
well that's everything from us for today
coming up tomorrow i'll be talking to
actor presenter and wwf ambassador kell
spellman about the first ever great big
green week
you can find out more about that at the
same time here on sky news see you then
you